hollywood's biggest stars stepped out
for the 28th annual sag awards last
night and i have to say it was very
refreshing to see all of the stars on
the red carpet i finally felt like i
don't know a sense of normalcy again
seeing them upright carpet yeah no it
was nice and of course morgan and i have
to chat about all the red carpet fashion
from selena gomez to will and jada
pinkett smith there was so much so take
a look at some of our favorites before
we break it all down
[Music]
[Applause]
that dress is just the color it stops oh
everything so i love that did you love
oh oh yeah yeah we're going to break it
down we're going to pick our favorite
okay so i need to talk about one of my
favorites at the gate selena gomez she
looks stunning in this puff sleeve gown
by oscar de la renta and can we talk
about those diamonds wow i just look at
that she's like tilting her head going i
am worth so much money
she's wearing a bulgari choker featuring
37 carats of diamonds wow wow wow i love
it from the sleeves i love that she wore
black but then that choker that's what
you're staring at yeah i like that she
had her hair back to just give the
attention minimal makeup looks stunning
oh she just looks so beautiful okay now
uh for me it's kerry washington yeah
hands down she brought the sunshine the
santa monica in the show-stopping
strapless
yellow ball gown by greek designer celia
chris ariotti i love the old hollywood
glam but i mean it's the color i mean
it's almost neon yellow like it's
stunning i just think she looks so good
from her hair to the side the bright lip
color
and then she had that moment at the sag
awards the tony goldwyn when they had
like their scandal reunion the whole
thing is just perfect can we also talk
about will smith and jada pinkett smith
they coupled up on the silver carpet in
matching navy blue ensembles jada
actually went with a vintage look
wearing this gareth pew gown she had
this in the back of her closet i love it
i love the whole idea of putting the
necklace over top they just listen they
understood the assignment they wanted to
do the whole matchy match thing and they
delivered even his glasses they look
like i went
the glasses is what put it over the top
yeah no they looked awesome okay now
cheryl and i we both love vanessa
hudgens she wore this custom versace
number i mean wow
i'm gonna say it easily one of the best
of the night she was so sexy with that
high slit it's simple yet elegant love
the bob what did you think of this one i
just thought it was so
feminine i think that it accentuated her
hips so beautifully just the way the cut
came in
um
no it was it was it was jaw-dropping i
think she looked and she knew it i feel
like she knew
i look amazing and that's that's great i
think truly this is the most confident
i've ever seen her she even that she's
posing properly but it's the color what
is that like seafoam like aqua yeah it's
foam green
yeah she looks incredible like bow down
let's not forget
john dutton aka kevin costner who made a
really rare appearance with his wife
christine baumgartner but unfortunately
for yellowstone fans we didn't see a
beth or a rip reunion i had feelings
about that oh i know you did i got your
text messages last night asking where
rip is
well i mean come on i wanted to see what
he was going to wear i want to see
beth's face i know i know so definitely
missing that but listen kevin costner
looks
good and so does his wife i mean they
both i i realized i was looking back to
see photos of them on the red carpet
this is a rare appearance for them and
boy do they ever look good he looks
incredible stem cell therapy i don't
know what he's doing lotions potions and
lasers like he looks
awesome no he does and so does his wife
i know and exciting i mean he's on one
of the most popular shows ever right now
so what a what an exciting time for them
all right now you know we always have to
praise keith urban and nicole kidman not
only are they so in love every time we
see them on the red carpet and not in a
gross way i love their classy pda i'm
just saying i enjoy classy pda but she's
wearing this classic saint laurent
velvet gown featuring an ivory bow i'm
gonna say this right now
i love everybody's dresses but if i
could choose any dress to wear this is
the one i would wear and then if you did
wear it i'd say can we take off the bow
i love nicole so much i think she's
timeless she's classic
she's amazing
it's the both i why what's wrong with
you i don't know i have feelings about
bows anytime something has a bow on it
i'm like can we rip that off oh no so i
don't it's disagree it's so timeless i
loved the conscious of her bright uh
blonde hair with the dark dress fine
imagine it without the bow no it
wouldn't be as cool it wouldn't be as
cool or would it or timeless